شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]
وحي الابطال
حاضر حاضر
ان اقدم لكم صاحب السعاده السيد زنسكي
رئيس اوكرانيا
[تصفيق]
شكرا جزيلا شكرا
شكرا
لا شعبنا العظيم شكرا لكم شكرا جزيلا
ايها الامريكيون الاعزاء
في كل
المدن
وكذلك المجتمعات كل اولئك الذين
الحريه والعداله الذين
في مساء
كل الاسر امل بان كلمات هذه
سيكون لها ساده في قلبي كل انسان في كل
امريكي وامريكيه ايها ايتها السيدات اريد
ان اشكركم على جهودكم وكلاء ذلك على دعمكم
ومساعدتكم السيده رئيسه
السيده غير رئيسه مجلس
الشيوخ السيده رئيسه مجلس
النواب اود ان اشكرك شكرا جزيلا انه لمن
دواعي السعاده والامتياز ان اكون معكم
استاذ اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الصدى الممثلين
عن كل الغرفه
انني
ايها الساده والسيدات اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
اه
الذين سيزورون اوكرانيا في المستقبل
وكذلك اود ان احيا
الجاليه
الاوكرانيه
[تصفيق]
اونر
من دواعي الشرف ان اكون امام الكونغرس
الامريكي وان اتوجه اليكم والى جميع
الامريكان واا كنا
فان الايام القاحله التي عشناها لم تسقط
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا حيه
شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
الاول
فاننا
ابنه
روسيا واعتقل بانه علينا ان
نتبع الخوف اوكرانيا قد فلحت وانتصرت وهذا
يهم العلماء برمته فان الامريكان قد
استطيع ان يجامعوا المجمع المدني لحمايه
الحريه وكذلك القانون الدولي
الاوروبيون ايضا انتصروا ولهذا فان همم
اوروبا اصبحت اقوى
مستقله اكثر من ما كانت عليه في الماضي
فان روسيا لم يعد لها تحكم علينا
وفقد تغريانها
[تصفيق]
اغنيه
الجهود نتاكد من ان ال ال نفرح ايضا في
المنطقه
سيكون لهم امكانيات الوصول الى الحريه
عندما سي يطيحون بالكرملين
نعم
فان المعركه تتواصل وعلينا ان نواجه
ونتصدى
المعركه ليست فقط للحياه وكذلك
او اي بلد اخر الذي تريد روسيا ان
تتسلط عليه فنحن نريد ان نجعل اطفالنا
واحفادنا
يعيشون»
بان همم
نوفر
الحمايه همم
الولايات المتحده والصين همم افريقيا
واستراليا فان
العالم مرتبط
وبعده لبعض وفي نفس الوقت فعلينا ان نكون
متوحدين اكثر عندما تبدا هذه المعركه فان
اممنا هي حليفه في كل هذه المعركه
همم السنه المقبله همم تكون
فرصه
لنتمكن من ان نصل الى الحريه الاشخاص
الذين يقفون اللي همم
ليله الجمعه
والسيدات من امريكا يوم امس قبل ان احضر
هنا الى واشنطن انني
خطي المواجهه في محمود
بالتالي ايضا
نيوترون الجيش
[تصفيق]
روسيا في السنه الماضيه كان 70 الف اشخاص
يعيشون في هذه المدينه واليوم لم يتبقى
الا بعض المدنيون فكل شبه من هذا البلد
وكلنا هناك معارض همم
[تصفيق]
لازالت صامده وكذلك اوكرانيا لا زالت
صامده
[تصفيق]
فان رؤوس
يستخدمونه كل ما هو في وسعيهم
في بخمود في هذه المدينه الجميله
الاندومي
لهم
فالتكتيك التي يتبعها الروس هي بدائيه فهم
يحرقون ويدمرون كل ما يرونه
مسروق
كلها هؤلاء الجنود وبالتالي
فان الاوكرانيين شجعان يفعلون نفس الشيء
على غير ما فعله
الجنود الامريكان
فان اوكرانيا
تستسلم ابدا
سوير
ضد الاشخاص الاحرار
من المهمه ان نحضر بالدعم حتى
النافحه وننجح في صحه المعركه
وشكرا على مساعدتكم
ولكن هل هذا لا اعتقد بالضروره وحتى نتاكد
بان بخموت لن تبقى قلعه فقط
لصدي
القوات الروسيه لكن يجب ان لا تنسحب كل
القوات الروسيه ولذلك فلا بد من مدافع
اكثر
يغير مسار حرب بنا حتى نصل الى الحريه
والاستقلال
وبيتاني فان المنظومه
تستطيع ان توقف الروسيين
هذا سيسمح لي الاوكرانيين بان يعمل
الدفاع عن حريته وعندما
اسرائيل اسرائيل
روسيا عندما لا تتمكن منها الوصول الى
مدننا فانها تدمرها
بالصواريخ
ولقد وجدوا حليفا في هذه السياسه وهذا
الحليب هو ايران وبالتالي فان الطائرات
مسيره لايران تسقط بالمئات على بنانا
الادونيتنا الاساسيه
وهكذا همم وجد ارهابي ارهابي اخر
وسايدربون ايضا واذا لم
نوقفهم فورا علينا ان نفعل ذلك
عامل ايه
ليس من محرمات في
ايطاليا بامكانهم ان يعملوا وان يهاجم على
المدافعات
الروسيه والطائرات يمكنهم ان يشغلوا هذه
المعدات انفسهم
[تصفيق]
inge التي وفرت امها لنا على
[موسيقى]
تقرر انه في المستقبل
رشا
هذا العدوان اذا اردت ذلك لكن يمكننا ان
نسرع من انتصارنا هو هذا سيؤكد لكل معتدي
بانه يمكن لاي طرف ان
اندرياس
وان يفرض من العقوبه
فالعتقد بانه
يسمم البلد
وكما قلت ذلك مع السيد بايده
بطبيعه الحال هناك بعض الاشياء التي يجب
ان نضمنها
للعقد المقبل وانني سعيد عيد اعلم بان
رئيس ايضا قد دعم مبادره اتجاه السلام
اليوم
يمكنكم ان همم
تتاكدوا
من
اننا نعمل ان نتلاقى من بطريقه
[تصفيق]
مشتركه
يمكنكم ان تعززوا العقوبات حتى تشعر روسيا
بان اهو مواصله هذا الحرب
ستدمرهم ايضا
اعتقد بانه علينا ان نجعل اولئك المجرمين
يتحملون هذه
المسؤوليتهم وان يعاقب الارهابيين
[تصفيق]
سبونج بوب
بنسبه لهذا العدوان وعليهم ان يجبروا
الدرر
وعليهم ان يعرفوا بان الولايات المتحده
متواجده وهي هنا
ايها
السيدات خلال يومين سنحتفل
بعيد المسيح
وربما بالشمع ليس لان ذلك ابدا ذلك لان
هناك لن نكون هناك اطياب كهرباء فهناك
الملايين الذين لا
بتدفئه ولا بالماء الصالحه للشرب وكل ذلك
نتيجه
الهجمات بالطائره المسيره على بنانا تحتيه
واننا نقارن
من له حياه اسهل ومن يعيش في غفاه ومن
يحدى بالامن
فنحن الاوكرانيون
نصل الى الحريه والاستقلال بكرامه وكذلك
بنجاح
[تصفيق]
نحتفل بعيد المسيح
وحتى لم يكن هناك تغييره تيار كهربائي
سيكون لنا اناره والضوء ايمانا وهذا لا
يمكن لاحد ان يطفئه وحتى لو
هجمنا رؤوس فنحن سندول قصار الجهود
لحمايهتنا ولو
جمونا بالطائرات
نحن سنذهب للملاجئ
همم
نجلس حول الطاوله
وهمم لن
تنجز كل امانينا لكننا نحن نعمل جميعا ذلك
اي الانتصار والنصر فقط هذا ما نعمل حقا
[تصفيق]
سبونج بوب
ومؤسسات قويه واشخاص اقوياء وذلك
بمساعدتكم وهذا يكون له
فائده لكم ولي الجميع والى جانبكم
وبذلك
مسؤول عن قام به
والان
وفي وقت وفي فتره الخاصه لعيد المسيح اود
ان اشكركم اشكركم جميعا اعتقد بان كل اسره
وعائله امريكيه التي
تتشبث
بالاسرتها وعائلتها همم
واهنئها واهنئ ايضا رئيس
الشيوخ وكذلك اعضاء مجلس النواب وانني
اذكر بلدانكم التي قدمت الدعم لاوكرانيا
والتي احببت
الذين رفعوا عاليا عالمنا اود ان اشكركم
جميعا
جميع الموجود على
الجبهه واشكر كل اولئك الذين يعملون لصالح
النصر انني اتذكر الحرب رئيس فرانكلين
وروزبال
وانني علينا ان نتامل ويتم معنا في هذا
الامر الشعب الامريكي
سيفرح سيصل الى النصر الكامل وهمم الشعب
الاوكاني ساسي يقلح ايضا وان ينتصر
[تصفيق]
الو
بان الكل مرتبط بنا وبيئه القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه لكن الامر ايضا يعول على
العالم
قد سلموا لي علما
علم مقلي معركه علم اولئك الذين يدافعون
عن اوكانيا اوروبا والعالم
وطلبوا مني بان
اقدم لكم هذا العلم الى الكونجرس الامريكي
الى اعضاء
المجلس النواب مجلس الشيوخ الذين سيتخذون
قرارات
تنقذ حياه الملايين من الاشخاص
اذن فليبقى هذا العلم معكم هذا العلم هذه
الغايه التي هي رمز لانتصارنا في هذا
الحرب فاننا سنناضل
لاننا موحدين امريكا
[تصفيق]
هناك شيء فقط
اخر شيء اود ان اشكركم مره اخرى
نتمنى من الله تعالى ان
ينصركم واتمنى لكم سنه
جيده وسنه
محفوفه بالانتصارات
[تصفيق]
فيسبوك فيسبوك
هذا العلم
كان فوق الكرتون